vamos a familiarizarnos con la
terminología de los osciladores
armónicos simples ya que tanto libros
como profesores van a usar estos
términos de forma indiscriminada y si no
sabemos qué significan podría parecernos
brujería matemática el primer término
que debemos saber es que si desplazamos
una masa de su posición de equilibrio y
por qué no lo haríamos es así como
provocaríamos la oscilación la mayor
magnitud del desplazamiento esta
cantidad cualquiera que sea la distancia
le llamamos amplitud y representamos la
amplitud con una a mayúscula y la
amplitud se define como la máxima
magnitud del desplazamiento al menos
para este oscilador así que esta masa lo
más que se aleja es esta distancia de
aquí y acá y dibujo flechas pero esto no
es un vector es la magnitud la magnitud
del desplazamiento es la magnitud de un
vector y por lo tanto siempre va a ser
positivo también
podemos dibujar esto aquí abajo esta
distancia es la amplitud ya que estamos
hablando de la máxima magnitud del
desplazamiento así que se va a desplazar
la misma cantidad a ambos lados de la
posición de equilibrio y esta cantidad
se le conoce como amplitud
si yo jaló esta masa unos 20 centímetros
querrá decir que estos 20 centímetros
son la amplitud o si lo quieren en
metros será de punto 2 metros lo que
quiere decir que cuando regresa hacia la
posición de equilibrio va a llegar hasta
acá y va a comprimir el resorte unos 20
centímetros hacia la izquierda así que
siempre va a ser igual en ambos lados y
hay otro término que debemos conocer y
este es el periodo al periodo lo
representamos con una t mayúscula y
porque se representa el periodo con una
t mayúscula ya que no hay una t en la
palabra periodo pues no estoy segura
pero como que esta t mayúscula suena a
algo relacionado con el tiempo así que
te podría representar el tiempo
y quizás esto es una buena idea ya que
el periodo significa el tiempo requerido
para un ciclo completo y qué significa
esto de un ciclo completo pues significa
que tenemos oscilaciones que están
ocurriendo por lo que este proceso se
está repitiendo en otras palabras si
tenemos que la masa comienza aquí
eventualmente llegará a este otro lado
va a comprimir al resorte y luego va a
regresar esto como que no se alcanza a
ver así que permítanme dibujarlo por acá
el tiempo que le lleva llegar acá y
luego regresar al punto de inicio el
tiempo que le lleva a hacer todo esto
que se repite una y otra vez se vuelve a
jalar hacia la izquierda comprime el
resorte y regresa donde estaba a la
derecha y esto lo hace una y otra vez y
no sucede nada nuevo aquí este proceso
se repite el tiempo que lleva realizar
un ciclo completo es decir el tiempo que
nos lleva reiniciar este proceso para
que la masa vuelva a esta posición
inicial es
periodo y siempre será el mismo ya sea
que comience a contarlo desde este punto
hasta este mismo punto o si me imagino
que mi tiempo comienza aquí de este
punto va a llegar hasta acá y va a
regresar este también va a ser el
periodo ya que es el tiempo que les
lleva regresar o reiniciar a la posición
inicial así que el tiempo que le lleva a
esto llegará a la posición inicial o
reiniciar le llamamos periodo va a estar
dado en segundos y para este ejemplo
para hacerlo un poco menos abstracto
digamos que el periodo es de 6 segundos
que significa pues significa que le
llevó 6 segundos a la masa y de este
punto llegará hasta acá y regresar de
nuevo a este mismo punto reiniciándose
ahora esto se está viendo un poco
desordenado y es por eso que muchas
personas prefieren dibujar como luce un
oscilador con una gráfica resulta que es
particularmente útil y elegante
representar esto en una gráfica porque
vean si dibujamos lo que sus
diremos bueno la masa llega acá se
regresa llega acá se regresa así una y
otra vez y pues nada más estamos rayando
nuestra imagen lo que no se ve nada bien
así que es mejor representar esto en una
gráfica cómo se verá esta gráfica vamos
a quitar esto y tenemos esto tenemos una
gráfica con la posición horizontal equis
y esto que es pues se refiere a esto a
la posición de la masa esto es x la
posición horizontal y está en función
del tiempo y quizás esto no les guste y
me digan a ver por qué ponemos la
posición horizontal en el eje vertical
no es algo raro quizás pero hace mucho
tiempo los físicos decidieron que si
están involucrado el tiempo el tiempo
siempre lo vamos a poner en el eje
horizontal y esto siempre se hace por
convención así que el tiempo siempre va
en el eje horizontal y si hay algo más
que queremos graficar pues la otra
variable irá en el eje vertical así que
vamos a estar graficando la posición
horizontal
en el eje vertical lo que significa que
mi posición de equilibrio y recuerden
que este es el punto en el que la fuerza
neta de la fuerza restauradora es igual
a cero y en este caso la única fuerza es
la fuerza del resorte que está dada por
la ley de hook es decir esta posición de
equilibrio va a estar donde x sea igual
a cero para que mi fuerza sea cero debo
tener a mi x igual a cero así que esta
posición de equilibrio de aquí esta
línea que le estoy dando un color
especial esta posición de equilibrio es
esencialmente este eje cuando x es igual
a cero ambas líneas representan lo mismo
representan a x igual a 0 y si jalamos
esta masa hacia la derecha
en esencia voy a ir hacia arriba en esta
gráfica ya que voy a una posición
positiva horizontal y si yo empujo la
masa hacia la izquierda en mi gráfica y
de hacia abajo ya que estoy yendo hacia
la parte negativa de la posición
horizontal
que esto no los confunda mucho veamos
como luce si yo desplazo esta masa
jalando la hacia la derecha como lo
teníamos acá jalamos esta masa hacia la
derecha unos 20 centímetros de su
posición de equilibrio y la soltamos
como se verá esto en la gráfica pues
comenzamos a la derecha y hasta acá está
mi posición inicial quiere decir que mi
gráfica va a comenzar aquí arriba cuando
x es igual a 20 centímetros y si usamos
metros que técnicamente es la unidad que
deberíamos usar aquí estará punto 2
metros y esto también va a ser la
amplitud recuerden que esto es la
amplitud esta distancia de acá es la
amplitud y que hace la masa pues va a
regresar a la posición de equilibrio que
es cuando x es igual a 0 y luego oscila
a partir de ahí llega comprime el
resorte y regresa en la gráfica vamos
desde esta posición hacia la posición de
equilibrio
llega a la posición de equilibrio que es
cuando x es igual a 0 pasa a través de
este punto de aquí y sigue hacia abajo
comprimiendo el resorte se detiene y
esto es cuando llegamos a este otro
punto en donde la masa es detenida por
el resorte y esto ahora va a ir en
sentido contrario este proceso se va a
repetir sube hasta la posición de
equilibrio y llega al punto en donde
había comenzado y esto es un ciclo
completo aunque aquí como que lo dibuje
un poquito más alto vamos a corregirlo
ya que nunca debe ir más allá del punto
en donde comenzó así que esta gráfica
luce así luego de aquí vuelve ir hacia
abajo llega donde vuelve a detenerse por
el resorte y el proceso se repite otra
vez si lo dibujará perfectamente esta
gráfica estaría perfectamente suave pero
bueno no la dibuje con exactitud aunque
yo espero que ustedes se den una idea y
ahora sí podremos dibujar las variables
de las que hablamos en un principio
como la amplitud y la amplitud que damos
que es el máximo desplazamiento a partir
de la posición de equilibrio que en este
caso es igual a punto dos metros que es
lo que representamos en esta gráfica de
aquí y también podemos representar el
periodo recuerden que el periodo es el
tiempo que nos lleva recorrer o realizar
un ciclo completo así que si nuestra
masa comenzó aquí para realizar un ciclo
completo nuestra masa debe de regresar a
ese punto y reiniciarse lo que estaría
acá por lo que en esta gráfica este es
el periodo el tiempo que nos llevó a
hacer esto es un periodo completo esto
es nuestro periodo t
lo que si recordamos que habíamos
escrito anteriormente el periodo era de
seis segundos así que este punto de acá
si nosotros contamos el tiempo desde
cero aquí aquí tendremos seis segundos a
la mitad tendremos tres segundos ya que
es la mitad del periodo o la mitad del
ciclo aquí tendremos nueve segundos y
aquí tendremos doce
segundos que serían dos ciclos completos
es decir ha realizado dos ciclos para
llegar a ese mismo punto y noten que no
tenemos que medir el periodo de pico a
pico podemos medir los de esto de aquí
abajo que algunas personas les llaman
valles o puntos mínimos así que lo
podemos medir de valle a valle ya que
vean de tres segundos a nueve segundos
tenemos seis segundos de diferencia nos
llevó seis segundos y de tres segundos a
nueve segundos lo cual sigue siendo un
periodo completo o podemos medir el
periodo desde aquí que digamos que 7.5
segundos hasta un 13.5 segundos que
también va a ser un periodo completo
solamente asegúrense de no hacer esto
pues muchas personas dicen a completar
un periodo para realizar un ciclo
completo pues voy a ir de esta posición
equilibrio a esta otra posición de
equilibrio pero este no es un ciclo
completo pues vean que en este punto
la masa va hacia abajo y en este otro
punto la masa va hacia arriba así que no
podemos iniciar nuestro reloj cuando la
masa va a este lado y detenerlo cuando
la masa está yendo a este otro lado no
es un ciclo completo ya que no se ha
reiniciado completamente si queremos que
se reinicie tenemos que medir cuando la
masa va hacia este lado hasta cuando la
masa vuelve a pasar por este punto hacia
la izquierda así que tenemos que ir de
esta posición de equilibrio hasta esta
otra posición de equilibrio para así
tener un ciclo completo así es cómo
luciría este ciclo completo en resumen
la amplitud de un oscilador armónico
simple es la máxima magnitud de
desplazamiento a partir de la posición
de equilibrio ahora podemos medir así o
la podemos medir así de cualquier manera
tendremos la misma cantidad el periodo
es el tiempo que le lleva a un oscilador
completar todo un ciclo el cual podemos
encontrar en la gráfica al medir el
tiempo que le lleva a ir de
a pico o de valle a valle o de una
posición de equilibrio saltándonos la
siguiente posición de equilibrio
llegando a la siguiente posición de
equilibrio